snitch on the toast but i'm bummed
snitch on the toast a snitch on the
toast but i'm bummed
snitch on the toast welcome back good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast we are so excited
humbled honored and thrilled to be
having our sister
the host of the snatcher the light of
our lives the apple of our eyes
margo ashrae in studio with us today
filling in for jackie oh hello
hello thank you for having me it's been
a minute when was the last time you were
on this show like the day you
quit no the day i got laid off remember
i threw up that morning and like i was
like not in
my right mind and then before that was
it old studio vibes
old studio vibes so for those who are
new here this is our sister margot
she's the host of one of our toast news
network shows this snatchler that'll be
returning
september in september when the new
season of the bachelorette airs we have
so many questions for you about the
bachelor as our bachelor bachelorette
resident stan correspondent um and
margaret used to work for us she used to
be on every episode sitting in the
corner
um just like being cute and annoying
yeah i wasn't annoying no you were
precious
precious i meant cute and precious yeah
yeah but freudian slip so yeah no
for sure and then she made it big she
left us she was working at a fabulous
job in fashion and
next thing you know at coronavirus hit
and she got laid off and now she's
slumming it with us
yes that is precisely exactly what
happened but we are so happy well i
am so happy to have you back here margot
is going to co-host with me today
she's going to deliver the fast five she
is going to dole out some advice on dear
toasters
and then we have a little interview
segment because a lot of people want to
know what life is like
for a post-grad laid-off fabulous girl
such as yourself considered post-grad
anymore if it's been a year
i think so okay that's good that makes
me feel better because now i feel old
and like you live in one of those
buildings where like everyone's
post-grad
you know honestly like i don't but yeah
it's just the vibe yeah it's the vibe
it's the area and if you're not
post-grad that like i'm officially old
so you are so we are post grad
we are both i recently graduated yeah
four years ago that's not that long yeah
i could have literally gone to like
dental school yeah you could be a lawyer
by now how does that make you feel i
mean i am a lawyer so it feels great are
you
yeah no i'm i object oh okay yeah
um so yes we have a fabulous show
planned for you guys today so much
excitement that the snatcher was back on
the toast and i i have to agree
the people are excited what do you have
to say to the people who have been
waiting for you honestly um
thank you so much for even caring like
i've been getting so many dm so i go
back on the on the toast and like i
didn't really think
anybody cared if i was on it so thanks
guys oh and now margo's a youtuber too
you got to plug all the projects
so many projects so because the last
time i was on here we were having like a
conversation as to whether i should
start my youtube channel and then
everyone was like you should do you
should do you should do it so now
i did it literally i did it
me and margo literally only speak in
tik-tok sounds so if you don't know
what's going on
take it easy um i did it
i did not me wrong [ __ ] not me wrong
[ __ ]
um anywho so i did it and now we are
sorry i'll stop i'll stop um i'm 13 000
subscribers in
yes you're literally my favorite
youtuber um
and i just really enjoy your content
even though like you don't do anything
you know but it's fabulous
because like i don't have a life right
now totally and what was it like for you
today
getting up at so well not that early but
pretty pretty early
doing dinner i went to sleep five hours
ago what's it like
um i had like a lot of flashbacks to
like when i did have a life and like i
did this every morning even earlier
and honestly like i thought i missed it
but like not so much
no the wake me and jackie always say
like we love our job so much and it
would be perfect if we didn't have to
wake up
yeah yeah like it was like two six hours
later but are you at the point in your
life where like you've been doing how
long have you been laid off slash
unemployed
um march so i guess four months and i
guess it's
not doesn't feel real because of the
pandemic and everything but have you
gotten to the point where like you sleep
until 12 every day and you feel like a
piece of [ __ ]
um do you watch my story do you feel
like a piece of [ __ ] yeah like a huge
piece of [ __ ] but it's not my fault
because i can't fall asleep till three
or four a.m and i'm not about to wake
myself up
at eight for no reason i just want to
say like if you wake yourself up
at eight for one day and then you'll be
on a normal schedule
honestly that's not true i've tried it i
just have a [ __ ] up sleep schedule i
even took ezekiel last night and i
couldn't fall asleep till 2 30.
z quill is a hell of a drug i know i
thought i thought i was [ __ ] because i
couldn't fall asleep so late and then i
was not gonna wake up at eight but
i'm pretty good i feel she did it and
she's wearing a blazer where's your
outfit from
honestly every piece is princess polly
besides the shoes
you look fabulous oh you're gucci shoes
they're not from princess paulie no no
no they don't sell gucci on there but um
thank you this was supposed to be like
my spring summer like work looks
like i had all that planned and then you
know a pandemic hit
at least you had clothes i'm still
wearing my winter clothes i forgot about
this i hadn't had the chance to wear it
yet well not that you asked but my
blouse is from margaret joseph's
collection and we support our fellow
podcasters out here at toast news
network
so thank you margaret for this beautiful
shirt that is very slimming and actually
fits me which is
so rare speaking of clothing um for
those who
may not know last night we uploaded our
third patreon of the month which was
a vlog that i spent all day doing i
cleaned out my closet
i went through you know some of the more
questionable pieces in my
wardrobe and you know with every vlog
you learn a lesson snatcher learn a
lesson
and what did i learn what did you learn
maybe everyone already knows this but
like i don't have a
sense of style like i don't have like a
fashion sense everything i have is like
weird and ugly and for mesos and i went
through and i donated like two huge bags
of clothing and the vlog ended up being
so funny
and ended up being really productive my
closet looks like so instagramable now
like so jealous
it's really good so patreon.com morning
toast
once you become a member for 7.99 a
month you get five extra episodes
for me and jackie sometimes their
podcasts sometimes their vlogs we have a
really fabulous vlog coming up i think
you guys are gonna like
um and then when you become a member you
also get access to our private facebook
group which is called
the toast after dark for patreon members
only and it's everything of the sort so
that's my shameless self promo for the
day back to the snatcher oh
um are you a patreon subscriber i am
are you not i'm not i'm not
wait what um honestly because i'm
somehow like logged into someone's
so like olivia's subscribed she's a good
sister
i've been meaning to and i tried once
but then like my credit card was really
far away
and then i meant to get back i promise
you i'll do i'll do it today no the
thing is is like i'm not trying to be
shady if there was a way to like give
friends and family like a free account i
would but i don't know how so it's like
anyone i'm always surprised when olivia
says she pays for it so i'm like you
could just log into our account
but olivia is a supportive mom yeah no
um i'm just somehow i think it's from
when i worked here i was logged into
your account and i just never left so i
did i never
really realized that i wasn't subscribed
until i realized so did you watch the
vlogs
yes i love the vlogs i do like sometimes
you watch mine yes
but after i said to you i added 12 more
minutes of content yes i didn't get to
see that one
interesting it's funny how things work
out no i mean i watched
what you sent um okay yeah no it's fine
sure um
but the time this goes up i'll be
patriot i'm memorizing yeah of course no
literally she's doing it right now
um so we have a fabulous show i think we
should just dive in because we have a
lot to do today and
jackie's not here she's usually the one
who like is in charge of like the timing
and the stories and like i had to pick
the stories today and of course
i picked the stories when not one thing
happened today like so boring
she was quite stressed when i walked in
yeah be stressful and i don't have an
ipad i'm like working off this iphone
like i'm living in the 90s your phone is
as big as an ipad no way nothing wrong
no take it easy okay have you ever seen
the original tick tock what that video
is from
yes it's hilarious hilarious that is my
favorite tick tock trend and when margo
says it and we're like drunk it
literally
it kills me yeah i just say it all do it
take it
okay before we jump in final question do
you think you learned your lesson
no no no okay do you think i did no
definitely not okay snatchler doesn't
learn her lesson and that's why the
chant is so perfect because we'll be
saying it till we're 90 years old
snatchler learn your lesson learn your
lesson
i'm glad we both stopped at the same
time okay
without further ado it is time to wait
oh my god i never see this
it is time to deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
so there really wasn't much going on
today a couple follow-ups from yesterday
but i would say the biggest and only
news of the day
is kanye kim dramalicious
moment um and here we go kanye west
hold on my page 6 is loading sorry this
is i don't do this wow
kanye west says he's trying to divorce
kim kardashian in latest rant
kanye west claimed he is trying to
divorce his wife kim kardashian while
also accusing his
her mother kris jenner of engaging in
white supremacy in the latest rant
from the outspoken rapper quote i've
been trying to get divorced
since kim met with meek at the waldorf
for prison reform in quotes
west wrote on twitter early wednesday
west apparently referring to
referring to a criminal justice summit
attended by kardashian and rapper meek
mill in november 2018.
quote meek is my man and was respectful
that's my dog
kim was out of line in the series of
missives
west then referred to jenner his
mother-in-law as chris jong-un
and said that the kardashians were
attempting to force him into psychiatric
treatment quote they tried to fly in
with two doctors to 50 150 me
kristen kim put out a statement without
my approval that's not a wife
that's not what a white wife should do
white supremacy
so this is a and he later deleted some
of the posts from his twitter feed but
this is a
day two of kanye's twitter and what we
said yesterday i don't know if you watch
the show let me just fill you in
um is that like while it's probably like
you know funny and cool to like make fun
of this it's obvious that he's like
really going through something
i think it's funny at all it actually
makes me really sad me too and the fact
that like people are like making memes
out of it when like this person's
obviously like this is a cry for help
he's having a manic episode
and this happens like once a year like
and it always happens on twitter and he
always gets treatment afterwards
yeah no i mean it just watching you sad
it's just like you're watching someone
spiral so it's like i don't understand
why anyone would
really like harp on that i just like
everyone like honestly
what bothers me the most is like the
articles that are coming out about it
it's just so condescending and like
everyone is just like jumping on it and
it's just like he clearly like needs
help so like let's maybe give them the
room to do
that yeah and that's exactly what jackie
said yesterday
um but i would be remiss if i didn't
mention that he's really fabulous at
making up nicknames for people because
oh my god when he called cory gamble
kanye i was
i was giggling i'm not gonna lie even
though it's a serious situation and
chris jong-un
is also i mean he's iconic he's an
iconic rapper that's like what he does
he's always been a wordsmith he really
is a wordsmith
um i don't know i just don't feel like
harping on this like i really want him
to get the help he needs but they say
every time kanye um
goes through one of these episodes all
these tabloids are like
kim is on the phone with divorce lawyers
and they say it every time so when i
read articles like that i don't really
believe it but to hear the d
word come from kanye's mouth even in
this state of
panic i don't know if it's different it
scares me for sure
what would we do i don't know what i
actually don't know what i would do if
they got a divorce
it would just be so crazy i know but and
i just like don't want it to happen i
just don't for the kids for everyone for
the kids i just
i can't and i think the cool thing about
kim is that like she's all the fireman
yeah she's all these things
businesswoman she's like a sex icon
but she's stands by her man and she's
like a wife she really does
always stand by him that's why i don't
really believe those articles because
kanye said the word divorce which is
crazy i guess
but that's also because like articles
are writing up about divorce so maybe
it's just in his head
yeah maybe maybe but again i don't
really feel like spending too much time
on this
because it does make me really sad and i
think people making a joke out of mental
health
um is not funny to me i won't laugh
no i won't laugh but there's more
kardashian news and this is something
um i saw a few days ago but i totally
forgot to tell jackie i wanted to talk
about so now that i'm in charge
the cameras have taken over from page
six style this is such an interesting
story
christian cowan is calling out khloe
kardashian for selling a loaned
dress christian cowan is airing his
dirty laundry with khloe kardashian
the designer has accused the 36 year old
reality star of selling borrowed runway
samples on her kardashian closet website
but we hear kardashian was never told to
return the items
at khloe kardashian he put on his
instagram story why are your run
why are my runway samples i loaned you
being sold on your website
an electric blue mini dress by the brand
was initially listed on the kardashians
resale website for thirteen hundred
dollars
a similar style from cowen's spring 2020
collection retails for 1950.
cowan also alleged that he has reached
out to kardashian's team multiple times
but has been ignored
we've emailed three times and had no
response he said but page six style has
learned that kardashian was never told
she couldn't keep the gown
the dress was gifted to her through her
stylist without a mention of a loan and
it was never asked to be returned an
insider told us
strangely the dress was later removed
from the website on monday afternoon and
a rep for christian cowan had no comment
the kardashian family has been
criticized in the past for selling their
hand-me-down clothing
on the kardashian closet site with
seemingly no charitable aspect involved
so
there's many layers to this but i just
want to address that last part because
a lot of people do think it's weird that
they sell their clothes like for money
um but i know that they have done a huge
hauls on the real real for like
children's hospital
right right i remember that so it's not
like they exclusively sell their clothes
without
a terrible funk but it is weird to sell
a dress
for money that you did get for free
regardless of the if the guy was
expecting it back if he gifted it to you
and you sell it for money that's weird
okay but what i have to say about this
is like i don't think khloe kardashian
knows what is being put on this website
and what is being sold like
i'm sorry this is an oversight probably
by her stylist or by someone who works
for her and like
yes it's gonna fall on her because it
was technically hers but like guys
she didn't just like she doesn't take a
picture of the dress and listed on the
ebay website take this and was like oh
this was gifted to me or this was loaned
to me let's like she wasn't doing it
maliciously like she has no [ __ ] idea
until this article comes out she
probably
isn't even in charge of that email yeah
it has the password someone got fired
someone got fired or got a big talking
too but like let's be real guys
it's not yeah it's not on quality no to
like photograph and
log all this information like to it's
like basically like running an ebay
store
photograph all the items put the
measurements all the dimensions and
upload it all to a website it's like a
lot of work and there's definitely like
a couple assistants or stylists exactly
like honestly a kardashian closet team
yeah well do that i've only ever seen
chris and chloe do kardashian closet
i think kim has done it but i've seen
them all do the real real like hospital
thing which is so cool because to be
able to own
a piece of kardashian history none of
them are my size so
jackie has a piece of kylie history i
all got really close to buying something
from the only person who's even close to
my size kris jenner
um and she actually has like fabulous
like resort where rich women's style
style
this [ __ ] sells out so fast i'm sure so
i don't necessarily blame khloe
kardashian like one can only oversee so
many aspects of her brand like to the
down to the detail and i'm glad that
they took it down um
but now it's like this is a like a
murky place to be because like with
loaned gifted items
if someone gives you something you're
under the impression that it's yours to
keep it's not to sell
no if someone gifts you something it's
yours if they loan it to you
obviously extremely different but then
okay so if they were expecting it back
like were they emailing asking for the
dress back or they were only emailing
once they saw it on a website
they were only well they claimed that
they had tried to get in contact with
her a few times about the
dress that's what he said to get the
dress back yeah
interesting yeah no it's just like it's
shady and like kind of embarrassing for
chloe yeah of course she doesn't need
this petty little drama she does not
need this petty little drama
speaking of not petty and not little
drama there's a lot going on with the
spears family
we also did a patreon episode all about
free britney if you're wanting to hear
more about that are you aware of the
free
pretty movement very aware yeah do you
support the free britney movement
yeah i think she needs to be saved i
think she needs to be saved as well like
it's clear that
she's being mismanaged yeah and i just
see like these really creepy tick tocks
of like
where like subliminal messages liminal
messages of like
you like zoom in and you see like the
boyfriend being like smile and just like
just
little things that get under my skin a
little bit well jamielyn spears has
entered the chat
okay and she is defending her badass
sister britney spears ahead of
conservatorship hearing
so there have been conversations about
mental illness on social media this week
after kanye west's first campaign rally
and online rambling sparked speculation
jamilyn speared shared tweets on the
matter from stars including halsey
on tuesday july 21 and took the
opportunity to address misconceptions
about such conditions
she captioned a picture which holds
these tweets were fabulous like if
you're if you need
i read them on the toast yesterday like
i just think halsey really put it
perfectly like why we shouldn't be
making fun of kanye
right i saw those and so jamielyn spears
screenshotted them and tweeted them
herself and her caption was
if you deal with mental illness illness
or care for someone dealing with mental
illness then you know how important it
is to respect the situation with privacy
for the person
and the family trying to protect their
loved ones no matter how it may appear
to the public
and as a public we must learn to do the
same i pray this doesn't bring shame to
anyone dealing with mental illness you
are not alone and you are loved
sending all my love and prayers to all
of you so i guess a lot of people
thought that like this might have some
you know hidden messaging i i understand
that so her well intended message was
met with criticism especially from one
commenter who questioned britney's
quote obvious mental illness in a
comment on the instagram post
the troll oh might i love that us
magazine refer to them as the troll
that's the only way the troll also asks
why jamie has not spoken out on the
issue and jamie responded to this
comment
you have no right to assume anything
about my sister and i have no right to
speak about her mental and her health
and personal matters
so true like i guess a lot of people
look to jamie lynn because she's like
really active on instagram
look to her to be as like some sort of
representative for brittany and the
family
right but like if i was going through
something you're going through something
like if i'm not talking about it
you can't talk about it no and literally
in if this girl read jamie's caption she
would know that she said mental health
is a private matter and the public must
respect it so then this commenter is
literally doing the opposite being like
ain't she gonna say anything right like
shut up it's personal
defeats the purpose of what you're
saying now can you imagine just like i
mean i guess you can't imagine because i
don't think you could really ever get in
the mindset of being a troll
but like imagine if you were trolling
like jamie lynn spears his instagram you
like left a nasty comment and then it
made news
um i actually one time oh no i didn't
troll it it wasn't like a troll i didn't
even realize i was trolling but there
was like i'm not going to name that
i know who it is it's a blogger couple
right he's a vlogger couple and i
i was like obsessed with them for a
really long time this was like five
years ago
and um they like always post together me
and my friend like always would send
their stuff back and forth and i
realized like
they'd been dating for so so long and i
was like they never say love you
so just like wrote that in the comment
and tag my friend like lol and like
i guess i didn't realize that they could
possibly see it the husband like
responded yeah like
responded and was like lol love you at
whoever the girl was and like it was
just
literally a fully put me in my place
yeah and like how did you feel
i felt like a [ __ ] loser i do but
like i didn't even realize
i was trolling and then i was like i
guess i was
no but the thing is is like you become
so obsessed with some someone or
something that
you don't even realize that at some
point you evolve into a troll of it
yeah no i i was horrified like have you
met some of the former toasters you know
i know i know like it's really like a
cycle where you become so obsessed that
the only thing to do next is just
i didn't say it out of hate i was just
like this isn't interesting to know like
maybe they haven't said it yet after
three years of being together
maybe next time just do it in the dms no
no maybe next time just don't [ __ ]
say anything
totally if you don't have anything nice
to say and by the way i never did it
again
no it's okay saturday learned her lesson
there snatchler
learned her lesson but can you imagine
like if you had these are like bloggers
so they're not like high profile but
imagine if it ended up in us weekly
i would die i would and you know part of
me really wishes us magazine like ran
this person's name just so we could
start scaring the trolls back on like
into their cabinets i think that's
considered doxxing because they're
probably
that's true and i'm not a i'm not a
supporter of doxing that's true yeah but
i feel like if you put something out on
a public platform
i know i don't know but they're private
citizens you're totally right and at the
end of the day like freedom of speech is
freedom of speech and everyone if you
want to hate me like that is your
american right to do so and it's also my
american right to respond
of course um now this next story is
something i'm fascinated by and it's
just such like an empowering moment for
women
okay um and the link won't load so just
let's keep talking okay now it's here
from e online natalie portman serena
williams and more stars are bringing a
national women's soccer league team to
la
the nwsl stands for national women's
soccer league
announced on tuesday that a professional
women's soccer team is coming to la in
spring 2022
while the team's official name and venue
partner have yet to be announced the
organization has formally
dubbed itself angel city in honor of its
new home the name and venue are expected
to be
revealed before the end of the year and
the team is being brought to la by an
investor group consisting of actress
natalie portman
tech venture capitalist karen norman
media and gaming entrepreneur
julie orman and venture capitalist
alexis ohanian
which is uh serena williams husband
tennis champs serena williams and
daughter alexis
olympia ohanian jr whom william shares
the reddit co-founder are part of the
founding investor group as well
making the two-year-old one of the
youngest investors in the sport the
daughter is an investor
yeah i am proud to be a part of this
wonderful group working to bring women's
professional football club to los
angeles ohanian said in a statement
chiefly because i'm a fan of the game
but also because i believe there's a
massive potential for the sport and it's
been undervalued by too many people for
far
too long love that as someone who spends
hours kicking around a football with my
two-year-old daughter i want her to have
a front row seat to this revolution
i'm personally investing on behalf of my
family because creating more
opportunities in women's sports is
important to my wife and to me
and we want to be a part of making a
better future soccer
football oh sorry soccer what did i say
but you said football but i know
football and soccer sometimes
when did i say football you just said
that they throw around the football all
the time and then you you also said
football to bring football to
is it football or soccer it's sucker i
never said football twice
i'm so glad we're recording no no i'm so
glad we're recording because we can oh
sorry ohanian called it a football club
you're right but okay but that's soccer
right yeah well i'm confused
yes he's okay yeah but he says out oh he
must be british because i as someone who
spent hours kicking around a football
okay okay well that was confusing thank
you i just like i knew i wasn't like
fully losing my mind
okay actresses jessica chastain america
ferrera jennifer gardner and eva
longoria are also members of the
founding investor group
in addition the group includes late
night talk show host lily singh
we love an influencer investor that's so
interesting like
i love just like a bunch of women like
rich women getting together and like you
know
forwarding the female quotient
yeah no honestly i didn't even really so
i don't know why i can't get it's a
soccer team
it's a soccer team in l.a in la that's
so fun
why don't we have soccer do we have
soccer teams all over the country we do
it's like not a really mls there's major
league soccer
for men is like kind of popular
and the uh the world cup american team
the women's team is
very popular they're they're fabulous
that's like ali krieger
girl like sorry wife um they're fabulous
they're everything of the sort and they
kill it and they literally make
no money compared to the men right
they're gonna come in 16th place and
still make
ten times world champions yeah so
there's actually been like a huge
conversation
around soccer as it pertains to the
gender gap because that's a perfect
example where it's like
people argue that like men's soccer is
like more you know watched and more
popular but like literally last year or
like the last time
american men's played they came in 16th
place and they made more money than the
women's team who won
i know i remember this it's [ __ ] wild
it's [ __ ] wild so
soccer is on the rise in america it's
really like a european thing i know
but i'm glad that the the rich women of
l.a initiative
they're not waiting for someone else to
do it they're doing it on their own you
know i like love that they're really um
innovative doing it all yeah i thought
that was a really cool story that is a
cool story i don't know why it was so
hard for me to understand but it's a
cool story
um was that five stories because i'm all
out um
oh no i have one more i was about to say
yeah you know doing the stories is hard
i have major respect for jackie i'm
sweating like an animal
every time i've co-hosted with you we've
co-hosted like four times together
that's a lot for you to be stressed
from page six katy perry taylor swift
ended feud publicly to be an example of
redemption
katy perry said she and taylor swift
intentionally chose to end their
long-running public feud
publicly while discussing her previously
tumultuous relationship with the lover
songstress
35 year old katy perry told howard stern
that appearing in taylor swift's unique
calm down video
provided young women with an example of
redemption
quote gossip and lies they take the
elevator but the truth takes the stairs
and it just takes time
time will tell my story perry said on
siriusxm's howard stern show what i'm so
grateful for is that we did get to
makeup and we made up publicly and we
got to be an example
of redemption for young girls what story
is she talking about i don't know it
seems like she's still harboring
somewhere
what what is she waiting for what's the
truth what even happened
it was like a bunch of [ __ ] with
some backup dancers oh yeah oh my god
maybe there's more to it but like katy
berry seems like she's
burying the hatchet but like keeping a
map oh yeah while holding in garage i
bury hatchets but i keep maps of where i
put
my reputation proceeds that was like an
amazing metaphor
yeah yeah the daisy singer said she and
swift now wish each other nothing but
the best
it's hard for young girls growing up
with cliques and high school and
pettiness and all that stuff
so now we're super friendly and i've
always wanted the best for her and we
could talk about
the best we want for each other swift 30
and perry's feud reportedly began after
perry basically tried to sabotage
an entire arena tour swift claim to
rolling stone in 2014
it wasn't publicly known that swift and
perry even had a feud until the magazine
cover story
which then let everyone believe that
swift's bad blood was about katy perry
so yeah it's something about dancers it
was never made it
like really clear but i agree that um
katy perry and taylor swift like both
intentionally wanted to put it behind
them because
they both try and be good role models
and it's really so petty that like
two girls in the same field like can't
get along no totally but i also just
like don't think that they
make good friends like just based off of
everything she's saying like i think
that they are genuinely civil but like
they're not
they're not trying to have a good
friendship because i don't think that
they're just going to have a friend
compatible like not everyone is meant to
be friends most people aren't
and the older you get you realize like
maybe you like you were born like near
someone or you went to school with
someone who like
you were just not meant to be friends
with oh my god i've learned that this
year like wholeheartedly yeah
you just you start to realize things and
you like
don't have to be friends with people no
no you don't have to be friends with
everyone no
i agree i think i may be taking that
lesson like a little too too hard
because i have no friends
but two i think it's better yeah i'd
rather quality over quantity
exactly um so with this katy perry thing
it does feel like she's still mad
or just like she's definitely holding a
grudge maybe it's just the way it's
transcribed maybe if you like watch the
video of the howard stern interview it's
like
it's light-hearted yeah but i definitely
am getting like a
mad vibe from yes 100 she sounds really
angry like the truth takes the stairs
like what the [ __ ] does that mean
oh my god i couldn't follow that one um
okay now that the stories are done like
i am stopping sweating can you chill
okay i can chill and we're gonna do deer
toasters oh i love that which is really
becoming a real staple here at the
morning toast for those who don't know
deer toasters is our advice segment it's
every wednesday and if you want to email
us we'll always keep it anonymous you
can write us in about anything from
i don't really know but just
relationships relationship work wedding
the email is dear toasters gmail.com and
we always keep anonymous you don't have
to worry about that and today we have
some good ones ready margo i'm ready i
mean jackie like
i always come out with like crazy advice
and jackie's like the one with like you
know the more
she like sees the big picture she's very
wise i feel like between you and i we're
about to dole out some terrible advice
hey jackson claudes oh okay we're on a
nickname basis
i'm dying my husband and i have been
married for five years and i've been
wearing my engagement ring for six
about four months ago i casually
mentioned upgrading my one carat
solitaire to two carat
my husband scoffed and said heck no
that's a representation of our love and
where we started
so i dropped it not the ring she dropped
the top i got it well flash forward to
this week when i woke up on friday
morning with no engagement ring on my
finger
just my plain old wedding band i'm a
crazy sleeper and i've found my
engagement ring just chilling in the bed
when i've woken up a couple times before
i've been convinced that i took it off
and maybe accidentally hit it while i
was sleepwalking that's how nuts i am
while slumbering oh wow this reminds me
of a story um
about a girl who swallowed her
engagement ring while she was sleeping i
remember years ago yeah
after tearing apart my entire house
searching high and low i still can't
find it
i feel terrible telling my husband but
he didn't seem all that upset because
insurance so my question is if and when
i get a replacement
should i request that second carrot i
brought up to i brought up six months
ago
i've proven i can't be trusted with
jewelry so how do i convince my husband
i still deserve a bigger better diamond
given my history thanks a blingy toaster
this is very interesting this is very
interesting it has so many different
facts layers well i just want to say if
you know that you're
like an animalistic sleeper which i am
don't sleep with your jewelry on i don't
right but what if she it might not
matter like if she leaves it on her
bedside table and she sleepwalks she
might do the same thing
just get a safe yeah maybe yeah
yeah no i'm not a therapist but if you
every time you sleep your subconscious
wants to attack your engagement ring
i do think there might be more to unpack
here but i'm not going to get into that
because it sounds like you have a nice
marriage
right no i think that that there's two
things that you could do here i think
you're right you get a safe and i think
that if you're getting a new ring yeah
duh
duh duh ask for the upgrade but then
also take practical measures
to ensure that this doesn't happen again
and just keep getting insurance you can
get a new ring every year
if you like lose it in your sleep once a
year right or just don't lose it in your
sleep by putting it in a safe
yeah but um definitely upgrade the ring
like there are some people like
unless she can get into the safe while
she's sleepwalking
wait why not why is she elon musk when
she's sleepwalking some people are like
so awake and alert but she said she
doesn't sleepwalk she's just like an
animal she said sleepwalk did she yes
she said she sleeps like an animal and
sleep i'm a crazy
sleeper and i've found my engagement
ring just chilling in the bed when i've
woken up a couple times before it
doesn't sound like she sleepwalks but
then she said that she's scared that she
hit it while she stop walked
oh yeah sleepwalking you're right she
did say that you've such a good memory
thank you
um this is a real pickle but the
question pique
the question she's asking is should i
upgrade the ring and the answer is 100
like i know that there are people people
love to praise like chip and joanna
gaines because they're like billionaires
and she still wears the ring the chip
gave her 45 years ago
personality trait while that's admirable
i would just never [ __ ] do that like
if i am a billionaire i want the ring
that reflects that of a billionaire and
i don't think that's so crazy
i agree um so i feel you girl like you
you've evolved in your life
you're upgrading upgrade that [ __ ]
there's no shame in upgrading there's no
shame in not upgrading either it's just
like i would never do it right
next up i hope that was helpful thank
you guys hi claudia and jackie i've gone
back and forth writing about
writing in because i've almost given up
but maybe you can give me a different
perspective
ever since i can remember my older
sister has always posted more risque
photos on her social media wow this
did you write this in about me margo
yeah sometimes i'll cringe because i
know all my relatives see it but i never
felt it was my place to say anything
fast forward to now my sister has now
started an only fan's account
oh man she promotes it on all her social
media all my relatives now know as well
as my parents i'm all about empowering
women but i'm worried she's gonna
go down a bad path selling photos of
herself i'm even more worried about her
safety
i know it's easy to say don't judge it's
her life who cares but when it's your
own sister it is much harder to do so
both myself and my mom have tried to
talk to her about it but she just shuts
us down as and is insistent on moving
forward with it
am i being too judgmental or should i
approach it from another way sincerely a
defeated steen
wait before you say anything i just want
to say we spoke about only fans and porn
a lot last week
and i got a bunch of messages and i
found something out that was really
crazy
i know what you're about to say a lot of
the free porn like on the internet
um is like they're the the stars are
either being like
trafficked or are being like manipulated
and like so mistreated and it's like
terrible
it's not like they chose to do porn like
now they're filming a movie it's like
there's so much more that goes on behind
the scenes of free
porn and that's why only fans have been
so embraced because it's like
it's people who want to work in the
adult entertainment industry like taking
back their power like making their own
content making their own money those
girls who like star in some of those
movies like literally get paid like 15
dollars
no i know so i take back what i said
last week only fans is actually a
fabulous platform
um but i could see like if your sister's
on it and you
that might make you uncomfortable right
and like so i was gonna say
at first like it's not her
responsibility if anything it's her
parents
because especially if they know about it
i feel like if
they want it to change like it's on them
it's not on her
but if they said something if they both
said something and she still
doesn't care i don't really know what
else you can do
but like be there for her i agree and
just like watch
what happened you know yeah no it's like
at the end of the day wouldn't you
rather she
be doing this on only fans which is like
a safe platform yeah
with your support so like you can always
be there for her if anything happens
rather than like then she cuts you off
because you're like quote-unquote
disappointed in her like at the end of
the day it's her life
and while that night might not be the
choice that you would make for your life
like i do think you have to respect that
it's her choice
and just try and be like a little less
judgmental if you can you can say that
you tried
to like get her to stop or whatever and
it didn't work which is fine to just be
there for her and i do understand the
safety aspect
like of them being scared for her safety
even though i don't really know enough
about the platform that i don't know if
your safety could be pulled into
question
i don't i mean it's like a it's behind a
pay wall so it's like really it's
actually very secure and i know a lot of
um like youtubers have started using it
mojo has one trisha paytas
i don't i don't think there's like any
shame in doing it like i know like
just because you wouldn't do it doesn't
mean someone else can right and i think
like we were raised to be like
conservative ladies but like at the end
of the day like this is what the girl
wants to do with her life and she's
making a good money money [ __ ]
yeah and she's feeling empowered like i
do think you have to just get on board
yeah
or not if it goes against you know
something like your religious values and
you can't
you don't have to support it but at the
end of the day if she's your sister and
you just want her to be happy like and
this is what she's doing and she's safe
and making good money and happy with
herself
and it's feeling empowered i think we
have no choice but to
to to support yeah i agree
that might be easier said than done
because we're not in her shoes but i
just think you should give it a shot
that's my advice um hi i've been
listening to the toe slash breath since
the beginning and i've been waiting to
have a conundrum to write about
i started this email at around 4am when
i realized that i perioded the bed
i wasn't supposed to get my period for a
few days so i did not sleep with a
tampon mistake number one
i woke up to go to the bathroom and
realize my underwear was a mess and that
my white sheets under where i had slept
were a mess too
my boyfriend was asleep next to me with
no clue what had happened i'm now wide
awake trying to figure out how to play
this situation
we were both we both work in school so
we are off for the summer and home all
day
he's an incredible guy and would clean
my blood filled sheets any day but
selfishly i don't want him to think a 20
his 25 year old girlfriend
can't handle having her period should i
just try and quickly wash the sheets
without him noticing
come back come clean without him
noticing looking forward to hearing
both of your takes love a seeing red
toaster okay
listen i don't know no you could do
whatever you want like if you want to
just hide and
hide and do it that's totally on you but
you can so be open about it also
just because you're 25 years old doesn't
mean you can't handle your period do you
know how many times people's period
comes early like
you don't know no it's so not your fault
as women we need to stop acting like
ashamed of our period no like literally
there's
absolutely nothing we can do about it
there's nothing we can do about it and
if you ever want to be
like here's an embarrassing story
that'll trump yours and
um taylor strecker told it to me and
it's the funniest story
and i love and it's about a celebrity
and i don't know if she's ever named the
celebrity so i'm not going to name
because i don't want to like
change names but um taylor schrecker
was at a fabulous party in la and this
major like mega star model
came in and sat on the arm of a couch
right by taylor and taylor's purse was
underneath
the um the ass of the supermodel
and she got up after an hour and it
turns out that the supermodel had her
period and actually bled on taylor's
purse
and instead taylor wasn't gonna say
anything she like didn't want to
embarrass but the girl turned around and
was like
oh my god i'm so sorry she literally got
taylor's address sent her a brand new
purse
and she was so apologetic when she could
have like gotten up and pretended like
and like literally like
just i mean she definitely did the right
thing no of course but like i just
thought it was cool how like she wasn't
embarrassed by it she like thought it
was hilarious i think she maybe even
like took a picture about it and like
tweeted it
um and it was just like a cool way to be
like open about it yeah and i just think
like if we
start running from our periods and
especially this guy he's gonna he you're
together five years
what happens when you give a baby and
you [ __ ] the bed in the hospital yeah
like
it's i think it's so you're getting in
your head about it it's really not that
big of a deal it's not that big of a
deal like do you know how many times
um ben and i in a hotel have had to flee
the scene when i stain the sheets like
it's it's a part of being a woman and
until we stop that's because you always
call your period over way too soon
that's true i do have a problem with
just like deciding i'm like hi my
period's over and my vagina's like but
we're still here yeah
um but that's just how i choose to live
my life and that is my right to do so as
a woman with ovaries
right so i encourage you to just be open
about it like and honestly i feel like
if
if there's a guy who like reacts like ew
he's gotta go he's gotta go because he's
a two-year-old and he's
not meant for you because you deserve a
mature man
yeah no no like when you're dating
someone with the point of getting
married that's like
you wanna have kids together you wanna
go through life together it's like you
want to be partners so it's like a
period is the worst
is the least of it right so if he can't
handle a little period stain
i'm sorry he is not the man for you and
that's on
period that time period um okay so those
were our dear toasters thank you to
everyone who wrote
in very brave of you um if you would
like
to ever write into deer toasters the
emails to your toasters at gmail.com and
like i said we
always keep it anonymous um okay
so i'm i want to talk to you okay we got
a lot of questions for you because like
i said you haven't been on in a while
right and there's so many been you know
like life life updates your new youtube
channel getting laid off and i think a
lot of people want to know what it's
like to be a fabulous girl living in new
york without a job you are a girl with
no job you should take over the
instagram
yeah um from larks rich
would you come back to the toast for a
full-time job while searching for a job
um i would however my position
has been filled and it should stay that
way and
i don't know i just i feel like it was
hard enough to leave once i don't want
to have to do it again
i'm sorry there's breaking news what
what kim kardashian has posted a
statement on her instagram story
no you don't have to look at your phone
i'm going to show you but i really want
to visualize it okay
as many of you know kanye has bipolar
disorder anyone who has this
or has a loved one in their life who
does knows how incredibly complicated
and painful it is to understand
i've never spoken publicly about this
how about how this has affected us
at home because i am very protective of
our children and kanye's right to
privacy when it comes to his health
but today i feel like i should comment
on it because of the stigma and
misconception about mental health
those that understand mental illness or
even compulsive behavior know that the
family is powerless unless the member is
a minor
people who are unaware or far removed
from this experience can be judgmental
and unders
and not understand that the individual
themselves have to engage in the process
of getting help
no matter how hard family and friends
try
i understand that kanye is subject to
criticism because he is a public figure
and his actions at times can cause
strong opinions and emotions
he's a brilliant but complicated person
who on top of the pressures of being an
artist and a black man
who experienced the painful loss of his
mother and has to deal with the pressure
and isolation
that is heightened by his bipolar
disorder those who are close with kanye
know his heart and understand his words
sometimes do not align with his
intentions
living with bipolar disorder does not
diminish or invalidate his dreams and
his creative ideas
no matter how big or unobtainable they
may feel to some
that is part of his genius and as we
have all witnessed many of his big
dreams
have come true we as a society talk
about giving grace to the issue of
mental health as a whole
however we should also give it to the
individuals who are living with it at
times
when they need it the most i kindly ask
that the media and public give us
compassion and empathy that is needed
so that we can get through this thank
you for those who have expressed concern
for kanye's well-being and for your
understanding with love and gratitude
kim kardashian west
wow i mean i mean that's what i wanted
to hear
from like from her that was her
basically squashing everything also her
signing off kim kardashian west i think
was a statement like i'm not getting
divorced
i mean honestly like i feel like the
kardashians over the years
have never drawn a line in the sand like
they open up about everything
big scandal kim's robbery in paris like
from the big stuff to the little stuff
they have literally let us feast on them
for everything no matter how painful it
is for each of them and for this i feel
like they are drawing a line being like
kanye is bipolar
and i feel like that's an appropriate
place to draw a line for media and press
right and if people don't respect this
like i will be really upset
yeah okay but like you know those shitty
tabloids are like gonna just live for it
live for it but i think she just needed
to get something out there and also like
that's for like
people like us like the people like just
like normal people i
like i wish the media would listen but
they don't listen to [ __ ] so yeah
i think that's just for like telling us
every like that they need their space
and you know i never really thought
about it because like if if someone's a
minor
and they suffer from bipolar disorder
like their
parent or legal guardian like they have
to do what the guardian
or parent says um but when someone's an
adult like they can make the decision to
not
get treatment yeah that's making it
really hard for the family and people
around them
right that's really sad honestly i just
really i i'm
sending positive vibes prayers wishes
everything because that's really
difficult to deal with on a normal basis
and at this level of fame they are i can
only imagine how like terrifying and
painful it is
i can't imagine but i'm glad she said
something
and i'm glad we were able to report on
it me too like i'm so glad we did such a
long episode because if that had broke
after
this episode and i just and i delivered
some shitty ass katy perry story
i know i know i know um okay
did you answer the question yeah i said
basically my position has been filled
and it should stay that way and i
i it's hard enough to leave the first
time i don't want to have to do it again
as the snatcher are you excited for
claire season what what did you think
about cl
the selection of claire honestly i loved
how diverse the men were and honestly
they looked very hot and like normally
from the photos like no one really ever
looks back
they looked very hot from the photos
which i can only imagine what they look
like
actually but i just have to say like i
just can't explain it i'm like not that
jazz for a season like i just want to
jump to matt james me too
from erin christine we need a detailed
apartment tour
i'm working on it i just have to clean
my apartment and i never want to do that
so are you going to do it on your
youtube would you do it for our patreon
it's going to be on my youtube okay um
also from eric christine are you going
to job hunt
and like are you job hunting i am job
hunting but there's nothing
like we are living in a pandemic where
the unemployment rate has never been so
high so like yeah i'm looking but it
doesn't mean anything
beta chokrien um which one of you or
nicole in your apartment has the bigger
bedroom
oh nicole that is such a good question
hannah mordecai
how do you stay so snatched during
quarantine um
well i've had nothing better to do but
to get slim and trim so like i've just
been taking advantage of the time that i
have
yeah clearly me too what's your favorite
online workout mine's open fit oh
duh um maya jordy what has your been
your favorite quarantine purchase
um i bought myself a computer and a
laptop yeah like a laptop and it truly
has like changed my life
okay it's pretty practical m ginder
would you ever have another scene on
your youtube channel are you trying to
keep it mostly to just you and your
friends
yeah that's true i have not been yet
honestly i just feel like
i would 100 have other people on it i
just haven't like
you know i mean like you're on my show
on youtube right now it's like a swap i
feel like it's only fair should we do
like one of those swaps you know
yeah who's your favorite youtuber
besides the morning toast i'm a
chamberlain
editor oh yeah what do you like about
her i don't know i just like
love her i think she's so funny without
trying to be and she has like such cool
style and i also think she's beautiful
and i also love that like she talks
about mental health in like not such a
serious way but she just like sheds
light on it and like
what i forgot major update in your life
is that you started going to therapy
yes how is that going it's good you like
it yeah do you cry
uh yeah yeah yeah all the time not all
the time
like every session no no no okay but
like most
most yeah do you feel like a bit like a
difference in your everyday day-to-day
not yet i mean i i i've only done like
five or six sessions so like i feel like
it's too soon like we're still getting
the download on my life
um but i feel like i'm getting like
tools to like help
myself when i'm like and all the
sessions are via zoom yeah which i hate
yeah it's like weird are you excited to
like get back in this i feel like i like
it way more
totally when it's in the office but i've
never done in the office um i really
want to switch gears like i know i'm
jumping all over the place but i wanted
to get your take on some of the news we
spoke about yesterday because we did a
lot of tick tock news
because there were so many different
updates in the tick tock world addison
ray um
announced that she's doing a spotify
originals podcast i listened to it and i
would like to know what you think about
that
idea as her next project and then what
the actual episode was like like do you
think that was the right move
i don't know if i think it was the right
move mainly just because i feel like
she's gonna do a few episodes and then
like stop
yeah um but do you listen to emma
chamberlain's podcast
no see i agree like i feel like it's the
same like i don't know why emma
chamberlain like did a podcast but she's
going strong
yeah but um i listened to it i've saved
24 minutes which is mad slow a lot very
choppy
a lot of like just like production like
music and stuff like that
like sounds um but i will say i was
impressed by
like how well addison was able to just
like host
because she was the one who was like
steering the ship and she did a great
job
um her mom they were talking about like
really private things so it made me feel
like you know when someone talks about
like private things that it makes you
feel uncomfortable to know these things
thousand percent
so that's how i felt but i was it was
interesting to like learn about like her
growing up and like her life
before all what did you learn um that
she like grew up with like in
like an rv or a trailer and then she
kept like
like she kept moving she was bullied a
lot like it was it was not what you
would expect honestly
so it was just like interesting and that
makes her rise to fame like all the more
impressive
i remember people always being like she
comes from money and i was like where do
you know that
right she like says this and i'm like i
don't know if that's true and then the
other major news was the demilio sisters
being the face of m2 the new morphe
brandon and people were like they don't
even [ __ ] wear makeup well that's
true and i did watch a video they did
in collaboration with james charles it
was like a sponsored video for m2
where they did a beauty battle and they
each had to do half his face and charlie
actually did like a bomb makeup look and
dixie literally did clown makeup and i
get that like dixie's thing is like to
be funny
and like do everything poorly like she's
a bad dancer but like when
you're the face of a makeup line like i
think it should
show in the video that you at least know
how to use the makeup and to me
i feel like it was like not good but
charlie actually did like a bomb
glitter like eyeliner moment yeah
charlie's just like everything
are you a charlie not to pit women
against another but are you like are you
a charlie or an addison girl
honestly i'm an addison girl me too i
just also like [ __ ] love her in bryce
hall
you do oh my god i think he's so hot so
according to you are they dating yes
okay so i don't think bryce hall is hot
at all but you know who i like wouldn't
kick out of bed
no back yes he's so cute how did you
know he's gonna say that because the
whole world's obsessed with him right
now oh really yeah well that video of
him like the one that like
started his career was the oh yeah
yeah he is handsome oh wait how old is
he
19. handsome oh my god oh i mean
and you know those boys like that's the
sway house yes
the houses have confused me because
there was the hype house and i totally
understood that
yeah hype is like no longer relevant or
if it is it's sad who's in hype house
like still will huddy thomas oh my
little huddy's so sad
yeah no no honestly you don't really oh
like nit what's his name alex warren
fake david dobrik
okay people really don't like it
when i read his comments like there's so
many i know
and i totally like i don't like like him
either but
he gets so much i mean tic tac hate is
like nessa barrett i
she worries me to be honest just justice
for her like i know she
she kissed the wrong boy but like come
on she gets
some of the craziest hate i've ever seen
like i don't know i don't know how she
does it
yeah and then it's like charlie and
addison who are like arguably the
biggest tick-tockers they get so much
hate too
but they get so many opportunities and
like projects and they're hanging out
with the kardashians
it's easier to stomach and swallow all
that when you're getting a fat [ __ ]
paycheck or when you're getting
paparazzi outside nobu malibu you know
but all these other kids are like
still relatively normal but like kind of
famous and i feel like the hate really
gets to them
it's really sad i mean i wouldn't be
able to handle it so back to morphe 2
what are your thoughts on the collab i
mean just the line in general
the so many things like they should have
named it something else like what about
morphe z if it's supposed to be gen z
m2 like like it's just like morphe point
2.0 like it's just stupid
oh is that what it's supposed to be like
yeah yeah it's for like gen z
makeup so it's like not supposed to be a
lot of makeup it's just like things you
could like like claire's making
yeah yeah um i mean listen they are
arguably the biggest stars in the world
right now so like good for them
and good for more honestly morphy morph
morphy i don't know what it's called
but um i do understand like the
the debate that it's like they don't
even wear makeup this this doesn't track
right but i'm happy for them me too um
a personal update and your life question
did you ever finish friends
no that is so weird i had the last two
episodes but i know what happens
but so why don't you watch it i don't
like feeling like nostalgic or sad
about a show you know that's really
short it gets to me
um what do you think about matt james
being the bachelor i mean i [ __ ] love
him
i actually can't wait have we met him
yes when we were at tyler's apartment
and he was so nice and handsome right so
nice and handsome so tall
um okay everyone i'm sorry i think i
just had one more questions for you
um from brennan thomas
welsh if you could pick any actress to
play you in a movie who would it be
margo robbie why do you think you'd look
like her no we have the same name
oh okay but she doesn't look like you no
miley cyrus looks like you like you get
celebrity doppelgangers like
take it asleep honestly why wouldn't you
want addison ray or libya
what did you think about the olivia copa
movie we watched the other day
i love her i love her too yeah and let's
just leave it at that yeah
um so that's it anything you want to say
promote
push um follow me on instagram subscribe
to my youtube channel it's just at margo
new video will be going up probably by
the time you
what's up margot my youtube channel i
changed it did you not know that it's
just margot yeah
is that snitch in the city no it's just
margo why don't we have a meeting about
this rebrand
uh i spoke to jackie about it
you did not you don't value my opinion
and then yeah
honestly i know i was just like i didn't
want to really do snitch in the city
honestly because my name wasn't really
attached to the youtube channel at all
so if someone were to search me it
wouldn't really come up
and then so i was going to do like my
name and then jackie's like you should
just do margo mainly because there's no
like influencers whose names are margo
and you should like hone in and
monopolize on that and i was like okay
it wasn't really a discussion it just
kind of happened in a conversation and
then i just did it
words can hurt i'm sorry that
i'm so you know you're no you're not i
know you're not
offended no you're not and it's fine no
you know it's you actually did me a
favor because now i know what you think
of me
and where we stand and i'm just going to
treat others the way that they treat
them to others as others treat them to
you you got it
you got it no you know that youtube's
like
you got it you you you got it i mean
literally all i do is talk and think and
watch me too it's so annoying because
people don't understand what i'm saying
so apparently there's been a rebrand
that i did not know about but it's at
margot
on youtube youtube my gosh try on
instagram
the snatcher returns in september
whenever we get a premier date from abc
is when we'll get a premiere date for
the stats that's very exciting thank you
so much for being here for having me
offering us your wisdom
and your insight and your beauty and
your grace thank you she's
she's she's great miss united states
that's all we got for you guys thank you
so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we go live monday through
friday 10 30 a.m eastern time oh no we
don't sorry i have to
have to come up with a new show god [ __ ]
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning chose milania morning show
where we post videos on our youtube
channel monday through friday and we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so that's spotify
itunes stitcher public video i heart
radio cast box all the places wherever
you listen to podcasts
find us the morning toast leave a five
star review about how beautiful stunning
and smart we are
goodbye
you